(people cinematically fighting)
- Bam! Slammer that coat.
- I love this bit!
(intense music)
- Okay, so this scene,
this is episode two.
This is our first moment
of peril together.
- It is.
- And all the bad guys are out to kill me.
And you're in danger by association.
And so, I'm gonna have to do
some slick gun slinging to get
us outta trouble.
And I think you're gonna
have to save my life, too.
(guns whipping)
(all cheering)
- Let's go!
- Slammer that coat! Spin! Bang!
- I will never forget
being under that carriage
watching you do this choreography.
- Yes!
- That's my favorite.
That is my favorite.
- That's real.
(laughing)
- Do you remember when you
were trying to teach me
how to do this and I broke
Freddy's phone at your house?
- Oh yeah, the machine gun.
This was so loud.
- Yeah, so loud.
- This was can't hear, ear
plugs in... need, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And then this, this we did.
There was a lot me jumping for this.
(gun shooting)
- I love those colors,
too, with that coat.
- Boom!
- Tell me you stole that coat.
- Oh, they didn't let me take
it, everybody wants that coat.
- I remember you doing that
move and I was off screen
way far away, taking little pictures
because I was just very impressed.
- Before I kill you, I want you to know
that I brought in a madman
to capture your Wraith.
My
Wraith.
- There she is.
(weapons clanging)
- That's cool.
(scary intense music)
- Hey.
- Terrifying, that mask.
- Yeah.
And me like trying to
get into the position,
that was not planned.
(laughing)
I thought they were
gonna cut that bit out.
(giggling)
What was so nice in this season is that
Inej kind of gets her own enemy to fight,
instead of like a group collaboration
of Pekka Rollins or whatever.
This is her story.
And what I really liked about this scene
in particular as well, that
it was a man being on top
of her and reminiscing her
time at the Menagerie as well.
So even though she could get
out of this very, very easily,
she was just kind of frozen in the spot.
Eh, there she is.
- Come to save the day, always.
(gun shooting)
Yeah.
This is one of the first
things I did with Danny.
- Was it?
- I think so.
So we actually filmed this
on my birthday as well.
- It was your birthday!
I remember.
(intense music building)
I love this bit.
That knife was actually
not a CGI, that was,
I actually threw it.
That was so much fun.
- This was three nights.
- Yeah.
- Very cold.
- Yep.
- Like, I had to keep
getting hand warmers,
so that my hands could
do the gun slinging.
- Thumbs up.
Yeah.
Here he goes!
(all cheering)
- You kept, that guy got
so much ash in his face.
- So much ash.
- What was that?
- It was like actor-safe powder.
- Yeah.
- So he didn't feel anything,
but it was so hard to keep throwing it
in his face.
- Final shot.
Boom.
(Kit imitating music)
- Smoking gun.
And if that is not a romantic scene.
It's so sweet.
That's so sweet.
- [Kit] Yeah.
- So it's Black Veil, then.
- And I love how you just
go straight for your hat.
You're like, "where's my hat?"
- Where's my hat?
(wall exploding)
- All practical.
- Was it all practical?
- It was a huge explosion, yeah.
- Yeah, tell me the truth.
Did he drop the guns when
he was gun slinging around?
- Never.
- Never drops his gun.
He never drops his gun.
(gun shooting)
(enemy wailing)